hello and welcome to swype coming up
breaking boundaries how you technology
is helping explore us push themselves to
their very limits the anti neknomination
movement we meet the man who's turning
the tables on the online drinking trend
racing for Red Bull our young racing
driver has haunted skills on the
PlayStation and we are cooking up a
storm with our food themed attribute for
years explorers have been pushing their
physical and mental abilities to the
limit alone in the wilderness early
pioneers like Captain Scott took on the
biggest of challenges but using only
fairly basic equipment communicating
with the outside world was all but
impossible but for today's explored us
with things like satellite technology
and mobile internet it truly is a whole
new world as Katie Spencer has been
finding out trekking for 105 days across
Antarctica's inhospitable landscape this
record-breaking journey by Ben Saunders
and taco lupini saw the British
explorers complete the longest human
powered polar journey in history
finishing for the first time ever the
ill-fated journey of legendary explorer
Captain Scott the equivalent of 69
marathons back to back in temperatures
as low as minus 46 an impressive feat in
itself but one which has also set a
precedent for future expeditions about
how technology can be used we had to
have two batteries at the same time it's
kit like this which allowed the men to
share their journey in an incredible
amount of detail taking a modified
satellite antenna used on board ships
charged with solar panels engineers were
able to help the explorers build their
own Wi-Fi transmitter be able to
communicate with it in our detail is is
something that is unprecedented I kind
of blogging to this this huge audience
and was um was pretty honest and open
about how we were doing and how tough
things were so it was it was even though
it meant another he knows that a half
hours a day of typing away and uploading
photos
it became a huge source of motivation
having a relatively lightweight setup
was key but that wasn't the only
obstacle the main sort of factor that
came into our heads immediately was a
temperature you know how do these
devices perform at sort of temperatures
which they're not being designed to go
at to test how the explorers kit would
work in such extreme conditions their
laptop was put into a thermal chamber
over a number of weeks somewhat
surprisingly engineers at Intel found a
domestic system that was able to take
the strain it is a much different world
for today's explorers you do find that
you've become reliant on it and there
are days when you've got a lot of cloud
cover when you can't use your GPS and
suddenly you've got to be able to use
old-fashioned navigation for Norwegian
adventurer live Anderson the first woman
in the world to ski solo and unsupported
to the South Pole the opportunities to
educate people are unprecedented we can
communicate with kids all over the world
that is a fantastic way to be a teacher
having fun being on the expedition
sitting in a tent and communicate with
millions of kids so that's a fantastic
at tool while the challenges remain as
tough changing technology does bring
home just how isolated early explorers
must have felt had a safety net that
Scott could never imagine so I think if
anything it just it gave me an even
greater sense of admiration and
appreciation for what they went through
hundred years ago while most of us are
unlikely to ever need to boot up a
laptop in Antarctica we are all likely
to benefit as research into how
technology can perform in such extreme
conditions trickles down into the
consumer market Katie Spencer Sky News
you're watching swiped coming up the man
who turned a neknomination into a good
deed but first if you like me play
racing games quite a bit you might fancy
yourself as the next Sebastian Vettel or
even David Coulthard the doubters may
scoff but one game that is proving that
the concept isn't entirely far-fetched
Jann mardenborough is racing in gp3 and
it was announced this week has been
signed up by Red Bull
their driver development program will
sergeant has more millions of racing
fans all over the world dream of being a
Formula One racing car the excitement of
driving it over a hundred miles an hour
round a track is an experience not many
people get to enjoy but Yan
mardenborough has moved one step closer
to reaching his ultimate goal I think I
am ready ready to move from a hundred 32
gp3 it's a step up from a logical step
up from form of the three and there's a
lot more powered by 200 horsepower more
power and more downforce bigger tires
and then yeah i think what live flashing
in front of three in various of a
challenges since cars I think I'm really
well prepared back in 2011 yanone the
right to go pro by playing gran turismo
on his playstation since then he's
completed in Formula three and now he's
preparing to racing gp3 for Arden
international just two rungs down from
Formula One the current f1 champions Red
Bull have taken note signing him up to
their driver development program is
driving career so far it has been
extremely intense
and he's coped with it so far so I think
this year is going to be again a pretty
intense season four and only with the
track activities but also the amount of
work that he's doing here on the
simulator to reach Formula One Young
will have to win the gp3 championship it
won't be easy but the young drivers
convinced he's got the skills to make it
happen I am hoping that we can that from
villain Pradhan they have been
championing GP GP 3 now for two years
and they've been successful in various
other forms of motor sport as well so
and yeah is that there's a lot to live
up to but I think I'm in the best team
and got the best around me at the moment
to deliver the best I can the World
Championship might seem a long way off
right now but who knows in a couple of
years time the route from the virtual
world to the racetrack could take Yan
all the way to the top well sergeant Sky
News you're watching swype coming up why
cats rule on social media but first
neknominate it's a craze that's
dominated the internet over the last few
weeks where people are filmed downing
drinks and dealing others to do the same
but now with the game linked to several
deaths what may have started as a
light-hearted idea seems to become a
dangerous trend however some people have
chosen to use their nominations to do
something good Brent Lynn deck in South
Africa made a video that went viral we
managed to catch up with them my first
thoughts are neknomination were why were
people posting something so ridiculous
online where everybody else could see it
I think that that people should be a
little bit more responsible with what
they post online and that's why when i
got my neck nomination I knew I had to
do something different all rights as you
know neknomination things going around
i'd like to thank Jared from my neck
nomination it originated from Australia
South Africa has got a huge portion of
our population that is hungry and is in
poverty I decided that my neck
nomination I would go and find someone
who was less fortunate than me and I
would give them a meal for lunch I'm a
snake nominations girl I knew you had to
nominate
other people to do the same so I knew
that something great could come of it
even if it was just in my circle of
friends within a couple of hours i was
already my youtube was hitting thousands
of views and and within the first couple
of days my friends had been on board the
next day 24 hours later there were
people that I didn't know that was
starting to pay it forward and do the
random acts of kindness it it just it
was a whirlwind of awesome deeds that
were happening around me the trend the
trains are all over the world hath
become global and and in England and
Europe they're calling it either the
rack nomination or the change nomination
and in Canada and America they're
calling it feed the deed and it's gone
global and everybody in the world seems
to be picking up on on the fact that
doing better is a better way of handing
it over it's a better way of doing the
neck nomination is by helping our people
in in their country and their fellow
citizens you're watching swype coming up
food for thought in this week's app
review but first here's a roundup of
anything you might have missed over the
last few days watch out Jeremy Kyle a
new projects underway to try and build a
lie detector for social media one of the
major problems with the merging news on
Twitter is whether or not what you're
reading is true but now scientists are
working on the tech to tell us whether a
rumor spreading on social networks is
just that project team will assess the
authority of Twitter's using their
online history with a view to spotting
wit accounts have been created just to
spread misinformation facebook founder
mark zuckerberg says the company's
purchase of whatsapp is all part of his
team's mission to make the world more
open and connected it's one of the
biggest technology deals ever in a
statement explaining why they'd paid out
eleven and a half billion puns Zukerberg
says the move is about working out
further ways of helping people to keep
in touch
the making of multi-platform hit candy
crush saga has announced its plans to
join the New York Stock Exchange King
digital entertainment top stories 300
million pounds from its initial public
offering and its value could reach 3
billion points that according to
analysts candy crush has played more
than a billion times a day but industry
professionals warned the company will
need to make more hits otherwise it
could be heading for a candy crash gotta
catch em all just try moving in this
game of Pokemon an online multiplayer
version of the original hit has seen
thousands sign up and join in the
catcher perhaps attraction is that tens
of thousands of players control just the
one character responding to thousands of
commands a minute your poker hero
doesn't get far quickly but surprisingly
together they've already managed to
finish half the game and finally it
turns out cuddles fluffy and whiskers
are all more popular than you on social
media new research shows that Brits
share nearly 4 million photos and videos
of their cats every day that's compared
to 1.4 million selfies and over 350,000
cat owners have set up social network
accounts for their feline friends while
it takes a social pet working to another
level naturally I could give Jamie
Oliver a run for his money when it comes
to cooking up gourmet grub in a hurry
you should see my [ __ ] or van or even my
deep-fried Mars bar but let's face it
there are times when we all need a bit
of inspiration in the kitchen so we are
spicing things up a bit in this week's
review with the help of food bloggers
leave shields so the first step we're
looking at is from very famous person to
UK Jamie Oliver and he has a lot of apps
usually tied into his latest books all
these books around there Jamie's app
model is you download for free and then
you pay for the extra bits so in 15
minute meals which is one more looking
at today you can have a look at a
certain number of meters which are
completely free another feature here if
you have the book or if you see a recipe
in a magazine from the book you can scan
it with your camera and it will give you
further details on the recipe or you can
pay 69p took a video if you want to
have Jamie in your kitchen helping you
cook at home the only thing about this
really is I've just been touching raw
chicken and now I'm handling a phone and
was also fat going everywhere so maybe
you want to set your phone propped
against the stack of books or something
like that because sorry hygienic
touching raw chicken and then touching
phone with Evernote food which comes
from the Evernote people who are famous
for their listing application which
millions and millions of people use you
have four sections in the Evernote food
app you can explore other people's
recipes and they are people who've used
Evernote foods and they have created
lists om for example we have good food
stories cookie and kate and they will be
bloggers who have really good list of
recipes you might want to look at so you
can look at your favorite bloggers you
can find new people the restaurant bit
is extremely useful it uses GPS to see
where you are and it tells you every
restaurant in that area which is
fantastic for me it's kind of a one-stop
shop for all the food things I do that I
want to keep track of and it's free the
third app is actually a book but it's a
brilliant book and I think it's a book
that many people in the UK aren't going
to be aware of it's from an American
food writer called mark bittman and it's
how to cook everything now what a great
title is that there's 2,000 recipes in
there the book itself is huge it's a
Bible and it's quite an expensive book
you know 30 40 pounds here you can buy
the app for 699 and it's all there in
your phone kitchen basics you know maybe
you're not that competent to cook maybe
you want to learn he tells you how to
stop you're covered it has you
everything to do you get his favorite
things the most popular ones from
everyone who's downloaded the app which
again is a really good feature featured
recipes and then quick dinners for that
friday evening when you just want
something quick before you don't know
what to tell you for the night another
app that's really good and i think it's
quite a fun app it's called time to
roast and it's for people who want to
make a sunday roast and maybe they're
confident about what to do or they don't
know they've got an odd size roast half
a kilo one point five kilos whatever it
is they can go into time to roast and
what they do is they choose their meat
from beef to goose to turkey everything
choose the meat you're using then say
this is the size and then ask for
instructions another one that people do
probably consider for their phone is
magazines that you can get for your
phone now with magazines that we publish
in the UK that's not such an issue
because you can buy them everywhere but
maybe magazines from abroad is something
that you might look into and one of my
favorites is called server it comes from
the US and it's very hard to find in the
UK but I can find this on the App Store
and I can download it for cheaper than
what it would be if I was to get it off
the shelf it's beautiful the photographs
are beautiful the recipes are very good
and the writing is excellent well that's
a lot for this week remember you can
catch up with the breaking text story or
week on Sky News for iPad or smartphone
apps and sky news.com we'll see you next
time